[Music]
kevin costner plays a stern but noble
leader in yellowstone but how does he
treat the show's cast and crew in real
life
among the band of toughnuts wandering
around and worn down denim and cowboy
hats in taylor sheridan's yellowstone
none can hold a candle to kevin
costner's john dutton patriarch of the
modern day dutton family head of the
family business and forceful overseer of
his children's various enterprises john
dutton is a man who routinely makes it
clear he is not one to be trifled with
lightly given such an effortlessly tough
exterior it only seems natural for
audiences to wonder just how much of
john dutton comes from the two-time
academy award-winning star's real
personality ryan bingham the actor who
plays walker on the emmy nominated
series might have a potentially
interesting perspective on the matter in
yellowstone walker is portrayed as the
odd man out among the various ranch
hands on the dutton yellowstone ranch in
fact in season 2 a particularly nasty
encounter with john dutton's right-hand
man rip wheeler nearly results in
walker's untimely demise so how does
bingham feel about costner in real life
and perhaps even more importantly do the
rest of the yellowstone cast ever find
themselves on the receiving end of john
dutton's signature menacing stare
thankfully the cast and crew of
yellowstone have offered information
about costner that paints the actor in a
decidedly different manner than that of
his stoic on-screen counterpart as
viewers might have hoped it doesn't take
long to realize that costner's
yellowstone persona is firmly confined
to the boundaries of the small screen in
a wide-ranging interview with the los
angeles times released in february
bingham covered a variety of interesting
topics related to himself and his job on
the set of yellowstone unsurprisingly he
also had good things to say about his
on-screen and off-screen boss bingham
revealed that despite john dutton's
tense nature the seasoned star behind
the character is actually a legitimate
joy to be around in fact bingham shared
one particular detail about costner's
onset behavior that makes him a true
standout in hollywood according to
bingham costner insists that he shake
the hand of each and every cast and crew
member every day
of course although john dutton also
seems like a handshake type of guy most
characters on the series can never be
totally sure that the hand being offered
by dutton isn't also gripping a revolver
while many could likely have guessed it
it's surely a relief to recognize that
costner isn't quite so tightly wound up
as the character he portrays
as the leading man of the series and an
executive producer too costner's
behavior on the set surely lays down a
tone for the rest of the casting crew to
follow according to bingham people on
the set of yellowstone often feel the
freedom to lighten the mood once the job
is done for the day and the camera is
turned off bingham said in the interview
we're always joking backstage and things
like that it's interesting how light and
fun it is when we're on set and we're
playing around people are chasing around
horses and things like that but then
when you see the show it can be pretty
dark despite the noted difference
between the series and real life one
particularly interesting aspect that
connects the two is bingham's penchant
for playing the guitar although lloyd
doesn't take too kindly to walker's
melodies in season four the real-life
crew appears to like it quite a bit
during a conversation released by
paramount network as a yellowstone bonus
feature a number of yellowstone cast
members noted bingham's regular use of
the guitar on set ian bowen the actor
who plays ryan said that bingham plays
the guitar constantly something everyone
seems to enjoy and he'll just get off in
his own world
and everyone stops what they're doing at
least you know if you're not working and
just listen to it it's a dream
given all the camaraderie on set in the
real world perhaps the perennially
stressed dutton clan could benefit from
taking a short trip out to the bunk
house too maybe they'll get the chance
when paramount network begins airing
yellowstone season 5 at some point later
this year check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]